Good Morning John!
We have recently reached a number of milestones here on the VlogBrothers channel.
We uploaded our 1500th VlogBrothers video,
We got our 3 millionth subscriber,
and we're about to upload our hundredth episode of Dear Hank and John,
as soon as you get back from vaction, no rush!
I think this is thus a good moment to take a look back. And we're gonna do that with the help of the WayBack Machine.
This is a product from the Internet Archive, you can look up any website you want to, like go to youtube.com,
and see what it looked like back in the past. Oh god, it's beautiful!
Oh, load it up! Wait, wait... I'm a male seeking everyone between 18 and- was YouTube a dating site?
This feels like information I should've had in my head! This is beautiful, but it's not what we're here to look at today.
We're gonna take a look at what youtube.com/vlogbrothers has looked like,
starting with today and moving backwards in time. YouTube has looked pretty much the same for the last, like, 3 years.
I don't super love it. I think we have to go pretty far back before we see a significant change in YouTube's design.
So now we're on 2014, same thing. Let's check out 2013... Ah-hah, this is new. I remember
this. This was the design for quite a long time, and I think I remember it being called, by Youtube,
Cosmic Panda? When it was first launching, it was like, 'Codename Cosmic Panda! The new design is coming!'
Look at this customization you could do, you could, like, all of this is image-mapped,
but if we continue to go back, back, back in time... we see that we've broken the thing.
Oh yeah, got a new one. Oh yeah, I remember th- I like this. You can design around it, you know, you knew exactly how it was gonna display,
but it's sad that we can't have as much fun as we once had. Let's pop into 2010 year, back when we had first launched VidCon.
Ah yeah, this design. I liked this, yeah, I remember doing this. Don't know what's happening all here with the blankness, but
we've got 344,000 subscribers. We are #82 most subscribed all time with that number.
That's different now!
Still pushing the Truth or Fail. It never worked! It was such a good show! I worked so hard on truth or fail!
Ohhhh, and it just- it just never- it was destined to fail. Ah, maybe with the new endscreens it could work?
I don't- don't, don't do it, Hank.
Alright, let's go to 2009. Alright, yeah, this one. This one that Sharkeye Jones did. Look at, this is gorgeous.
Doesn't this look better than what it looks like now? One of the Short Sisters, Monica, now works for VidCon.
She's running PodCon right now. August 2009, we have 98,000 subscribers, so we're about to hit 100,000.
And look how nice all this looks. I don't know how we ended up with just John's face as our channel icon.
Alright, we're gonna pop all the way to 2008 now, and probably lose this cooler design and end up with-
yeah, this! Oh god! Edit undo. And then, on the sidebar here, you got like comments on the channel!
I think that we have like one channel design left before we are out, and here it is. It's the first capture archive.org
had ever made of VlogBrothers. We had 9,700 subscribers. Latest YouTube drama, subscribe to HouseholdHacker,
YTwatchdog has 20 videos removed due to TOS violation. Renetto says the YouTube community
is on its last breath because of telemarketers? There has been YouTube drama since there has been YouTube.
MisKChief says, 'So since you have cracked most subscribed, guess you can [sic: can't] just stop making videos.'
Back in 2007. We thought about it, in December 2007. Absolutely. We said we were gonna do it for a year,
we'd been doing it for a year, we had 11,000 subscribers. That was super big, back then. It is not super big now.
But, yeah, we decided to keep doing it. Turned out okay.
Our final archive.org archive is from December 1st, 2007. So basically, there's no record of our YouTube channel
for the first 11 months that we did it. But John, if you remember, in the early days, YouTube was not where we, like,
has our main community. We had it at brotherhood2.com. And if we go back to 2007,
I think that we're gonna get... Oh yeah we are, oh yeah we are, check it out!
"Discussion questions: how should Hank take Nerdfighters to the next level? How comes horseradish
looks like mayo and tastes like poison?' We don't so discussion questions anymore, that's fun, how about this one?
What was the first book you ever loved? That's a good one.
John, thanks for doing stuff with me. I've been recording for 36 minutes, so there's proabably a much
longer version of this video over on Hankschannel. John, I'll see you on Tuesday.